what is up
ladies and gents we're going to talk
about the game engine i've been working
on slash game i've been working on i
guess it's more of a game engine than a
game but i intend to make a game so
don't you worry oh yes ancient archer
it's still going on
don't give up i haven't okay so uh
i've been working on this on stream a
lot i uh for like a whole week
i was getting up at like 4 30 in the
morning like jocko willock but instead
of working out i would go work out my
fingers on the keyboard
yeah true story so i made a trello board
for it and check this bad boy
wow what is my green screen doing stop
it green screen just
okay whatever okay yeah i knocked out a
lot of stuff i made it a more standard
engine where uh yeah i made the includes
like everybody else does their includes
with open source libraries
i worked up the lights i synchronized
the shader some which i will show you in
a second
and i basically been sorting out some
bugs or trying
and i have a whole bunch of stretch
goals over here for things i'd like to
get done
actually this phong lighting kablam
kablam there's a little more to it than
this
because right now it it only does
the specular lighting as a flat vec3
not a texture so it could have
improvements
on it this is like basic font lighting
but hey we're gonna call it
probably done so i got a lot of stuff to
do as you know i'm working on
a series with opengl and teaching you
guys all about shaders and stuff and at
the same time i'm implementing it
in my project so pretty cool thing
because uh
not only do i get to implement it but i
get to teach
it at the same time which helps to stick
in your memory all right let's check out
the project let's see how it's doing all
right so let's
check this bad boy out so yeah big thing
i did actually let's just look at it in
a folder view because that makes a
little more sense
so a big thing you're supposed to do in
case you don't know and i might make a
video on this topic
on its own but if you're making a
library because that's all this
essentially is
is a library that you can just go you
know you can include and link
to your project and you can start using
all this functionality which is just
like graphics and sound and a bunch of
game stuff basically interested
so yeah under the main include there's
another folder with the name of the
project because that's how you're
supposed to do it and then the only
header you need to include
i used to have this as a singleton class
which really made no sense and i was
just doing it to do it i guess because i
honestly don't know why i was doing it i
was just uh playing around
so now it's just a flat structure of all
the stuff
in a name space and yeah there's all the
the header functions
look at them i've just been sorting it
out and organizing it
it's uh i don't know let's just run what
we got here so i made a little demo
project that is included
on this branch and all it does is let's
start from the top and initialize the
engine
and then it creates a camera with the
height and width that's the same as our
screen
because that makes sense we set first
person controls which this could be a
whole block of code but i just put it in
a header
to get it out of the way but essentially
could copy and paste this
right into here it just sets up fps
controls for the mouse and keyboard
and then we load up the skybox right
there
i want to change that it needs to be
better but it works for now
and then i load up some sounds as sound
effects and music all seems to work
it's not perfect but it works it works
good enough and then i load up a bunch
of models that i got from
mixamo had enough had enough of this
green screen
stop it we're going to 92 102
how high do i need to go up to make you
stop show in the background okay 112
looks pretty good
all right that's better that's already
better now it's just going to get
things that aren't even green because
because it's so high on the matching
thing all right
and then we also move the objects around
a little bit
just so they're not all stacked at the
starting location
and rotate them a little bit and then i
had a spotlight i
was playing around with a lot of lights
a lot and getting lights to work
and i made like the shaders that are
built into this like automatic so you
don't have to like manually load up
shaders
basically when you load up an object you
now say whether it's lit or not
this last thing so if it's false it's
just going to get diffused if it's true
you're going to get all the lighting
and it'll just automatically work you
can have things that are lit and not lit
within your
scene because maybe some ui things you
don't want to consider the light you
just always want them to be lit up or
something so that was kind of the
intention
but it's a little better i'm still
thinking of other ways to make it
even better but it's a little better
than it used to be
so it's it's moving forward so yeah
there's a spotlight there's a point
light there's directional light and they
all have
a handle that's what these integers are
here
and they're static so we can access them
within our lambdas that we create to add
to the functionality because the way
this engine works in case you don't know
is initialize it you add stuff to it
and then or you run which is way at the
bottom here
and i guess you can do it while it's
running too but before you run you add
the to these update functions there's a
bunch of update functions that have
different ways of working like there's a
delta update and you have to
make a lambda that passes in a float
which is the delta time
so that way anything in the delta time
you can move with delta time considered
and for example we have a little
flashlight on i guess this doesn't use
delta time so this should actually not
be in here
just notice that so i could just add it
to the normal update but it's fine in
the delta update it's not going to hurt
anything
so if your flashlight is on and i have a
hotkey down below
to turn it on and off if it's on it
moves with the player if it's off it
just doesn't do it
so there's that and i think i just have
some uh
just some math here to move the other
lights around so you could actually tell
what was going on
however i commented them out so it's
kind of pointless to have all this math
in here now
so whatever it's just a big test it's
just a big test file this project one
so if we look at it i know i'm jumping
around a lot here but it's just the way
my brain works sometimes
so if we look at this and go to like
directories you see that i have included
the ancient archer engine and then
include here so that way
we just uh yeah we can do this sort of
thing and get it all in there so that's
all you need to do if you clone this
the main core engine part all you
literally do is go
file or well i guess we do it up here
you just go add
do project whatever you want to call
let's do
empty project project three sure why not
actually right click go to
references or add reference and just
reference the engine there
that'll handle all the linking and then
you can also go to properties
and well you can manually path to the
include but you want to make sure this
is all
all and then here you would say yeah
solution er
or whatever the path is to ai engine say
engine
include and that's it and this is ready
to use
we can now make a new source file add
new item
source file sure and boom we can just
start
going so that is like the standard way
to use it right now
um until further improvements now to to
be
this wouldn't be that hard for me to
like port to linux or other os's or
not use visual studio or for me to make
it so it works with other build systems
but that this thing is changing so
frequently right now
that if every time i made like a
semi-major change i had to also redo the
build systems it would just be a giant
pain so that's why i'm just sticking
with visual studio and once it's like
closer to finalized or those versions
being released then i might consider
hey uh just use cmake and generate for
whatever you want
but uh yeah i'm just kind of putting
that on the back burner because the
great thing about visual studio for all
its many many flaws
is uh well it kind of automatically
manages all your build stuff so you
don't have to worry about it and you can
just keep coding
and that's kind of what i want to do i
want to get all the code sorted out all
the libraries
it also kind of does the libraries
automatically if you're using
vc igbc package manager so that's really
nice too
rather than have to manually go set up
the libraries build them and link them
you can just use vc
pkg and i have a video on that which
i'll try to remember to throw a link up
there in case you don't know how to use
that but it is like the best
most simple way to pretty much get any
library
sorted out and set up on your computer
it takes like seconds compared to every
other method
and then yeah you can just start using
it however you want you can start using
the the engine
all you really have to do is initialize
it
with a knit engine and you can just well
i guess we could go straight to run
honestly and it wouldn't do much like
let's go ahead and run this
so you want to have a bunch of stuff in
between of adding things and setting to
the
update functions and stuff which we'll
go back to in a sec but just want to
make it clear that it's like literally
this easy to use
and start a new project with and yeah
that's just a blank purple screen
because that's the default
but you can do whatever you want with it
so let's go back to project one because
that's the one that has all my demo
stuff i don't know how much you guys
would rather see
maybe the back end of stuff or how much
it's you how to use it
i guess from like uh kind of imagining
from someone watching perspective you'd
rather see
how to use it rather than like what's
going on behind the scenes so there's
the delta update
there's the add to key handling which
takes the keyboard input by reference
and you basically just check if whatever
button you want or mouse button and you
can have it do stuff you can see i have
something on mouse button one
it plays the sound mouse button two
plays sound pressing minus changes the
volume equals changes of volume
u gets a plane state i don't know if i
need that a lot of this stuff is
like i said it's just test this is not
this is not a great example of
a game it's just like examples this is
just me testing things as i
add them and making sure they work and
stuff and then timed out key handling
another version of the key handling
this one has a timeout you can actually
change the timeout you can go
i think it's uh set timeout
or i don't know it's somewhere in there
set time there's a set keyboard timeout
length
there's also a slow update which that's
the function that just came up there
set slow update timeout length because
there's an add to slow update which only
updates like every half second or second
or whatever you set it to
so if you don't need something to check
every single frame every single update
then you can
set things to update only every once in
a while with that function
so it's just a way to save on
performance for things that
can suffer from a delay without a
problem
but the timed out keyboard basically
anytime it returns
false then it doesn't start a timeout if
it returns true what you're supposed to
do on a successful key press
if it or if it successfully activates
whatever you're trying to activate
you're supposed to return true
then it sets a timeout where you can't
press it again kind of like a cool down
it's a bit janky and i guess i haven't
these actually shouldn't be here because
they're not timed out they should be
up in this one so yeah usually when i'm
working on this particular file that i'm
showing you i'm just like doing it as
quick as possible because i don't care i
just want to see if whatever
i'm working on is actually working
properly like whatever i'm working on in
the engine i want to see if i can
implement it and get it to work properly
so
this is totally a test big old test
there's turning the flashlight on and
off it's on a timeout
because some things if they're not on a
timeout and you press the button once it
gets spammed like a million times per
second and it's just weird stuff happens
so that's why these timeouts are nice
there's some other stuff to change a
light color
what this does pressing n toggle point
light
and then we run and you see i did have
add to slow update
update the play buffer because when
you're playing music you have to uh
update the buffers every once in a while
and that works fine with the slow update
because you don't need to do it every
frame just every once in a while so
let's go ahead and run this
i'll show you what this looks like with
some models and sounds and stuff
there it is there's a bunch of lights
you can't really tell where the lights
are coming from
but i can toggle that directional light
off i can toggle the point light off
and now all i've got is a spotlight on
my camera
background is not considering the light
since it's a skybox so
i should probably close it off or turn
it off if we really wouldn't get a
better idea
because like as you can see there's some
specular lighting on these guys
at least a little but if i turn it
completely off they go completely dark
because there's no lights
turn on the directional light here which
is like the sunlight
you can see they light up some and point
light back on there's a point light like
right in the center here that's really
bright
so that's what that is but yeah uh
big old test so that's where the
engine's at right now i guess the next
big phase
um i might have a little bug there with
the shininess i need to check that
okay well the next big phase here since
i've got
some of the lighting stuff like kind of
sorted out it's not too bad
and it could be better is probably the
animations
once i get some animations going i'll
actually feel pretty comfortable making
a game so i can make like a static game
i could make like i don't know
tetris or anything that doesn't involve
like animating characters would work
pretty well in here right now
but as soon as you get to starting to
animate stuff with like you know your
your whole animation graph that's not in
here yet that's that's like a really big
thing i want to add
before i start making a game and you can
see a whole list of other things so
it's a work in progress it's a very i
don't know i'm plugging away at it i do
want to hire someone i do have an open
position to work on this so if you're
interested in working on game engines
and developing something new and unique
and think you could uh
help out with this feel free to hit me
up or if you're just bored
you're welcome to work on this uh off of
github too it's on there it's open
source
and even if you you're not interested in
any of that and you just think it's cool
go give it a star on github it does help
its visibility and
helps uh helps it advance so links down
below
also consider becoming a patreon of this
channel to help this channel out there's
also a discord so if you have a lot of
questions about this coding stuff or
whatever it may be or you just want to
talk to more coders jump on the discord
all right well thanks for watching
that's where ancient archer is at these
days
i guess the last thing i should probably
mention is this
if you look at it on github the branch
i'm working on is called isolation 2
this way i had a master it's got all
this new stuff so all these old branches
are pretty old versions at this point
the one i was just showing you is
isolation two
so keep that in mind as well if you're
looking at it here and not seeing the
stuff
but yeah there it is thanks for watching
i'll see you guys soon real soon peace
out
[Music]
you